hello there obi-wan kenobi has fallen
under a lot of scrutiny lately i think
one lackluster aspect about the show
that most people can agree on is that
the writing at times is not very good so
instead of making another review
covering the show i think it'll be more
fun and insightful in analyzing the most
jarring writing issues and normally i go
chronologically for these types of
videos and try to cover everything but
for obi-wan i want to cover the biggest
problems instead so firstly let's look
at revo the third sister
as we find out through episode 5 ravel
was actually all along working towards
the goal of killing darth vader and
apparently darth vader was aware of this
although it's a bit unclear as to
whether he learned that from the grand
inquisitor who miraculously survives a
lightsaber through the stomach or from
as far back as reiva being a youngling
since darth vader called her that this
leads to this development being
extremely convoluted because why the
hell would darth vader actively employ
reva knowing the entire time that she
secretly wants to kill him you can argue
that he was using her to find obi-wan
due to her dedication to the task but
all the other inquisitors were actively
disinterested even though darth vader
gives them their commands and he clearly
still wants to find and apprehend
obi-wan so why only utilize one
inquisitor because of this this feels
like a writer's ploy to make rava have
more value within the story and
especially since she's always
conveniently on the right track and
knows more than she should the first
major example is her in episode 3
finding and capturing leia the entire
process of her sifting through this
random building finding hidden
compartments is really confusing because
does the force turn her into a goddamn
bloodhound can she track the scent of
people the force at this point is
becoming more and more confusing and it
seems like the writers are using it as a
way to create mcguffin mechanics to move
the plot forward so rava somehow finding
a secret button that opens up a secret
passageway seems overly contrived for
her to catch leia not to mention that
leia got a massive head start and rava
somehow teleports in front of her which
also brings up another confusing thing
of why would there be two different
passageways leading to one place and why
wouldn't tala tell leia about the
supposed faster way that rava ends up
taking and this is just one example of
rava conveniently knowing things to move
the plot forward there's also the moment
in episode 4 where she has the
clairvoyant foresight to bug leia's
droid for the complete off chance that
obi-wan rescues her and they somehow
manage to escape because at that point
in time she's in custody and has no
knowledge of obi-wan being in the
compound so it's practically impossible
for her to predict this specific set of
outcomes that will lead to leia getting
away then there's also the small moment
where rava immediately snuffs out tala
as being an undercover spy it can be
kind of obvious from an audience
perspective but the second she walks
into the room you just know that raid
will figure things out not because of
her character but because of how
conveniently the writers have been
granting her the ability of gravitating
towards the solution like hell even in
the first episode she manages to find a
needle in a haystack and threatens to
kill owen out of an entire crowd of
people which also branches into another
inconsistency of plot convenience in
that if rava has the ability to read
people's minds then why threaten to kill
owen when he can just force read him i
know this would have ended the show
really early but if you're going to have
a contrived tension-inducing scene or
rava almost kills owen then it should at
least be consistent to the internal
logic of the show so most of her
supposed victories and finding out
information feels cheap and fake in
order to make her more important as a
character for me that's pretty damning
and ruining one of the villains of the
show but all this lead up just that this
supposedly really smart character that
can predict leia's escape decides to try
and kill darth vader when he's in a suit
and screams while doing so is dumb
why would he choose this exact moment to
kill darth vader because why wait until
after darth vader's force holding a ship
from going off to try and kill him let
alone you know finding out where he
lives or break into his personal
quarters and killing him while he's in
his back to tank to be fair though an
assassination attempt on darth vader is
kind of silly regardless given how
powerful he is to begin with then after
being caught she's stabbed in the
stomach for a second time with a
lightsaber this isn't like getting shot
with a bullet this is an entire pole
sized rod that disintegrates anything in
its way and when you're getting stabbed
in your stomach region then the
lightsaber will for sure strike an organ
for the grand inquisitor you can kind of
argue him surviving given that we don't
know his alien anatomy but for a human
if your intestines or stomach get
deleted then there's no way you'll be
able to survive
you managed to avoid all the important
bits
what is that right i mean the
liver
the liver
i don't even know what that thing does
all of this utter nonsense in writing
just that she can try to kill luke and
change her mind at the last second is so
stupid from a writing standpoint he may
as well just have killed her but at this
point they're bringing back so many
characters and are going to be using
them into infinity so in general i think
reeva is a complete mess of a character
from a writing standpoint and her
existence in the first place is really
confusing since darth vader already
knows who she is
darth vader and obi-wan's first
encounter comes across as a complete
head scratcher
firstly i always hate the trip where the
heroes need to get away but they stop to
watch something that wastes their time
and thus puts them in more danger this
is what happens when obi-wan delays
their own escape just so that he could
see darth vader i know he probably is
really curious about seeing him but his
absolute priority should be protecting
getting leia off planet immediately but
hey we need to give fans a scene of
darth vader brutalizing random people
from the perspective of obi-wan then
similar to rava darth vader uses a force
like a bloodhound and tracks obi-wan out
to a mining area which i always thought
the force mechanic of sensing someone
was more of a presence thing of an
entire area like oh i sense that darth
vader's on said ship instead of a very
specific place that you can then track
but whatever i could very well be wrong
or more likely the writers are just
using it as a means to get these two
characters together
so the showdown between darth vader and
obi-wan personally i feel like it's kind
of weird to force these two characters
together this early in the show and
probably should have waited until the
finale thus building up the suspense to
their inevitable showdown which would
also allow more time for obi-wan to get
his powers back but the midway showdown
inherently feels cheap because of a
obi-wan kind of just throws himself into
a position to be pursued by darth vader
instead of quickly escaping with leia
and b obi-wan will have to get away from
darth vader and in doing so you will
have to create a contrived scenario for
him to get away
unless if you are a good writer which
isn't the case here instead tala
conveniently is able to find obi-wan and
darth vader because there's a random
tunnel that just so happens to lead out
to the area in which they are fighting
and before helping obi-wan darth vader
is torturing him in fire which is a
genuinely interesting development since
darth vader hates him so much that he
instead wants him to suffer instead of
killing him after dabbing obi-wan on
some fire like a marshmallow darth vader
force pushes him away which extinguishes
the fire and right away i don't know why
he would do that and then tell the
stormtroopers to go and get him why not
force pull obi-wan towards himself
instead of away then tala reignites the
fire that separates darth vader and
obi-wan this seems like a really easy
fix for darth vader to solve he could
either simply force push the wind again
that he literally just did 10 seconds
prior to put out the fire or simply
force scribe ob1 again to bring him back
or even just walking around the fire at
this race what happens instead is them
getting away and it's as if darth vader
intentionally lets them leave despite
him desperately wanting to capture and
torture him so as i said before the
writers clearly wanted to have darth
vader and obi-wan clash before the
finale but couldn't come up with a
logical means for obi-wan to escape
darth vader and it's not like their
fight was particularly that good given
that obi-wan is primarily running away
and that on its own is kind of a silly
sight to see and what's even more
ridiculous is darth vader teleporting in
front of obi-wan on four separate
occasions as if he's jason voorhees from
friday the 13th i know a lot of people
like any form of fight scene they get in
star wars but you can't ignore the
glaring writing flaws that are on
display here
next let's look at obi-wan's plan to
infiltrate fortress inquisitorius
and to throw this out right away this
entire episode is kind of pointless
given that we lose lei in a really dumb
way just to get her back again so this
kind of feels like filler in terms of
progression though raven learns the
position of the rebels in the end of the
episode but what would have made more
sense would have been darth vader
planting a tracking chip on obi-wan
during their confrontation and that is
the reason why he let him go instead of
him just awkwardly staring at him and
not pursuing him but whatever we now
have to save leia again for the third
time and obi-wan asked rokan for help to
which he very strongly says no until he
goes on about his sob backstory and then
he immediately changes his mind without
any persuasion from obi-wan and he
agrees to help them wow how convenience
while this is all happening reeva is
interrogating leia and at one point she
finally uses her forced mind reading
ability leia being that she is force
sensitive is able to resist it and reiva
even admits that she is strong which
wouldn't this immediately throw up a red
flag for rava if you physically can't
read this child's mind then the only
possible explanation for that is that
she's force sensitive and that's why
she's resisting but this moment is
quickly brushed off and for how much
raven knows everything i'm surprised she
wasn't more suspicious of leia's force
capabilities this scene should have
played out where reva discovers that
leia is force sensitive and is about to
entomb leia before being saved by
obi-wan instead of him randomly walking
into the tomb and leia not actually
being there and it's like he's wasting
time as she's about to die or be
tortured but going back to obi-wan and
talo's initial infiltration it's pretty
tense especially for tala as she's
almost found out and has to reinforce
her higher rank to another guard however
there is always issues with these types
of infiltration scenes in which the
security detail seems extremely light
and there are never any security cameras
or why would he put a camera in this
droid that moves around and not in a
stationary position that has constant
coverage of said area and on the subject
of defense capabilities of fortress
inquisitorius they also have no aerial
defenses given that some air speeders
were able to do a strafing run on the
base or let alone the space having any
tie fighters on hands so if they get
attacked then they can't do anything i
guess
but going back to the infiltration
obi-wan finds a team of the fallen jedi
right away this feels like a leonardo
dicaprio pointing meme scene where fans
try to spot all the easter eggs which
raises the question how were all these
bodies captured in their final moments
did these inquisitors force freeze them
on death or are they not actually dead
did they put these jedi back into their
death poses i don't know and the team in
theory seems like a cool concept but in
execution there are a lot of questions
since they breeze over it so quickly and
it doesn't come back up again while
obi-wan is gawking at all these dead
bodies or maybe alive bodies lei is
about to be tortured or killed or
whatever and it's kind of funny to see
obi-wan's sense of urgency inevitably
though obi-wan saves leia and they catch
back up with tala and in order to get
leia out of the fortress obi-wan opts to
hide leia under his coats this has to be
the most ridiculous thing in the show
and from this alone it feels like the
writers are writing this for children
how does no one notice this obvious kid
hiding under a trench coat they're
walking past hundreds of stormtroopers
out in this massive room like what i
feel like this reinforces the notion
that stormtroopers are legally blind
then upon getting to the hangar rava
stops obi-wan from getting away which
immediately contradicts their plans of
letting them go and finding the ripple
network why we're stopping them and
recapturing them given that they are
surrounded by stormtroopers when you can
simply do nothing and achieve your
supposed goal but nope we need to have
an explosive escape sequence that again
showcases the utter incompetence of
stormtroopers and they get away now
another logical explanation is that reva
could have told everyone else to let
them go and that's why no one else
noticed a child under a trench coat but
that's not even the case because later
it's revealed she told noah her plans so
yeah this entire episode is a
devastating headache and the defense of
the rebel base is just as bad
the rebel outpost defense may be a bit
overshadowed by the cool darth vader
moment of him force grabbing a ship but
everything leading up to that moment is
pretty ridiculous starting with the
notion that leigh is now an engineer at
the age of 10 let alone lay at any point
in the original trilogy really
showcasing that ability and even after
scouring through the first three movies
the only moment i could find was her
briefly turning a lever in the
millennium falcon and empire strikes
back and that was it so this trend of
giving kid characters so many adult like
personality traits and skills is pretty
absurd and the second it happens you
immediately go
yeah right a 10 year old cannot do that
and it immediately breaks your immersion
and suspension of disbelief and it's
also kind of funny that everyone is
entirely dependent on this kid to fix
the issue so the amount of trust is
massive and is of course unrealistic
again
after that obi-wan gets a transmission
and gets interrupted by tala obi-wan
doesn't really say anything to her and
for whatever reason she starts to drone
on about her tragic backstory it
basically comes out of left field and i
immediately thought the writers are
trying to force the audience into a
sympathetic view of the character
right before they kill her off which is
exactly what happens
then rave inevitably breaks through the
door and somehow dozens of stormtroopers
managed to miss rebels barely hiding
behind cover like how is this possible
it's probably just as hard to miss given
that there are a bunch of rebels
standing out in the open
it's literally shooting fish in a barrel
but the stormtroopers can't even manage
that i know in the original trilogy they
had notoriously bad aim and i feel like
that was always george lucas giving his
heroes plot armor
which as a result the enemies always
missed but here disney's writers are
just running with the concept of
stormtroopers being utterly blinds and
it makes any action scene the right at
this point feel completely tensionless
and unintentionally comedic because to a
degree it's okay if they miss a bit but
to this extent that they're showing
right now it's way too far-fetched i i
just can't suspend my disbelief anymore
before opie wants to renders and talks
to rava he gives his stuff to hajja one
of the important items he gives to him
was the message he received from bail
organa talking about luke during their
sudden evacuation hajja drops it and
turns around to look at it and
apparently leaves it on the ground which
is so stupid and is such a contrived way
to have rava figure out this information
like obi-wan kenobi just gave you his
possessions and you drop it and don't
even care to pick it back up what then
it doesn't even stop there because
obi-wan tells rava that while darth
vader is focused on him she should take
him out to which she lets him go and i'm
assuming she wanted him to escape given
that there were only a couple
stormtroopers on him and he obviously
breaks it loose but the confusing bit is
that obi-wan just flat out leaves in the
ship without personally distracting
darth vader unless if darth vader
holding the ship was when rave was
supposed to attack and not after it
squandering her window of opportunity so
rafa suddenly turns into a dumb
character so that she could get skewered
and conveniently find the message that
haja dropped i already went into the
whole fiasco of her surviving but yeah
this whole sequence was very convoluted
and messy
before going into the finale let's
briefly touch on princess leia since
there are a lot of different aspects
surrounding her that are either
confusing or are written in a stupid
manner firstly let's look at her
characteristics as a 10 year old because
young lia feels like she's written by a
middle-aged man who doesn't know how
kids act mentally she is like an adult
and any soon she has with obi-wan she's
basically always running circles around
him and bossing him around not to
mention her being witty and charismatic
all of these characteristics packed into
a 10 year old flat out doesn't work it
comes across as disney wanting young
lady to inspire kids however you can do
that without overloading her to the
point where she starts to become a mary
sue because at that age she shouldn't be
able to evade bounty hunters in obi-wan
kenobi being able to intelligently think
her way out of situations when obi-wan
seemingly can't in comparison and even
being a mechanic it feels like this is
written for kids when star wars should
have an all-encompassing age demographic
let alone the obi-wan vs darth vader's
story being really dark which some dark
elements bleed through like darth vader
torturing obi-wan but then that's
immediately contrasted against leia
having her comedic chase scene then
there's also the notorious retcon for
leia wearing a new hope leia's message
said this and i can't play the clip
because there's copyrighted music so she
says general kenobi years ago you served
my father in the clone wars now he begs
you to serve him in a struggle against
the empire so this line in her message
to obi-wan indicates that she doesn't
know him and instead knows her as this
man who served her father in the clone
wars which you'd think that leia going
on a massive adventure with obi-wan
would at least be somewhat memorable so
this doesn't really line up with a new
hope in terms of this being a problem
it's not that big of a deal but since
this retcon exists it will forever feel
like latest time when the show is forced
and there's also another small retcon i
found in rogue one where bail organa
mentions obi wan
friend
jedi he served me well during the clone
wars and he's lived in hiding to the
emperor's purge yes i will send for him
yeah i don't think he's exactly been
living and hiding considering he just
saved an entire group of rebels leia and
fought darth vader twice so far and it
seems like disney wants to continue on
with this
and then lastly i'll touch on the final
episode since this is the most recent
thing that came out
now this is by far the best episode for
obvious reasons however there is one
aspect that really drags down the
enjoyment which is that each of the
climactic scenes are shrouded in
darkness especially for a tv setup
because man did i have a hard time
seeing what was happening before
rewatching it on my monitor now the
devordologic aspect stems from the fact
that this show reportedly has a budget
of about 25 million dollars an episode
so it's mind boggling that their
creators chose to have these scenes take
place at night with no dynamic light
sources besides their lightsabers it
doesn't really come across as being that
expensive to produce on top of the fact
that no lightsaber fights take place in
that good of a set piece in comparison
to the films from the concept art i
thought they would hearken back to
revenge of the sith and incorporate some
lava but that never showed up if
anything when darth vader did his
awesome earthquake force move i thought
he could at least reveal some lava to
light up the scene which unfortunately
doesn't happen then for rave's emotional
scene you can barely see her given that
her entire costume is black so she's
almost invisible and for a second i
didn't even realize she was crying then
despite the action and choreography
being great for darth vader and
obi-wan's fight scene the editing is
sometimes jarring which again goes
towards the 25 million budget and i'm
really confused why they couldn't have
cleaner action with longer takes
especially since they are already
cutting corners by having very limited
light
then for one other devotologic aspect
about the finale that really bothered me
was how incompetent the star destroyer
was i guess they also have terrible aim
now and shouldn't they also have tie
fighters why do they have to make the
choice to go after one of the ships just
deploy a squadron on one and keep the
star destroyer on the other but yeah i
covered the main issues with the show
and there are still dozens of small
writing mistakes splintering throughout
the show like obi-wan going out of his
way to disable a laser gate when he can
simply walk around it or these guards
clearly seeing obi-wan sneaking around
but they have plot armor obstructing
their vision i could go on for a while
but the video is already getting long
and i feel like i've already proven my
point of how poorly written some aspects
of the show are thank you for watching
and i assume most people who have
disliked this video probably already
left so thank you for sticking around